[Música]
el gobierno francés buscará aprobar el
presupuesto del estado sin consenso y
aferrándose a un artículo de la
Constitución la oposición respondió con
el anuncio de una moción de censura
contra El Ejecutivo que van a presentar
este mismo jueves Tenemos reporte desde
París
nuevo cambio en el gabinete del Reino
Unido a la ministra del interior anunció
su dimisión al gobierno la segunda
salida de este tipo en apenas una semana
se marcha por haber usado su correo
personal para compartir información
oficial Cómo afecta esto a la
cuestionada primera ministras lo
analizamos desde Londres con nuestra
corresponsal
el presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin
declaró la ley Marcial sobre las cuatro
regiones de Ucrania anexionadas en
recientemente el crimen otorgó también
poderes adicionales a los gobernantes de
estas zonas Mientras tanto el parlamento
europeo reconoció al pueblo ucraniano
con el premio sácaro de Derechos Humanos
tiempo de actualizar las noticias aquí
en la pantalla de France 24 Gracias por
continuar con nuestra señal Yo soy Juan
pupiales comenzamos esta emisión
informativa en Francia porque la primera
ministra Elizabeth anunció que el
gobierno buscará la aprobación del
presupuesto del estado sin consenso y en
su lugar van a recurrir a un artículo de
la Constitución que les entrega poderes
para sacar adelante este proyecto nos
vamos a París con nuestra corresponsal
con nuestra periodista Natalia Ruiz
giraldo con quien vamos a analizar esta
noticia Natalia ya la oposición anunció
que habrá una moción de censura contra
El Ejecutivo esta misma semana
esta misma semana y de hecho ese
documento ya fue depositado porque la
nubes que es la coalición de izquierda
que reagrupa a radicales de izquierda
socialistas ecologistas y comunistas ya
tenía listo ese documento mucho antes de
que Elizabeth pues ya explicará ante el
pleno de la asamblea nacional que iba a
recurrir precisamente a ese artículo el
49.3 que les permite pasar o adoptar
esta ley sin necesidad de el voto de la
asamblea nacional la primera ministra
que explicó que en vista de que se
habían puesto
más de mil enmiendas que querían hacerle
a este texto pues nunca se iba a lograr
debatir ni votar en los tiempos que se
necesitaba y que además ya se sabía que
la oposición Pues iba a votar en contra
de este texto además de esta moción de
censura que ya fue depositada por la
nupes también reagrupación nacional el
partido de ultraderecha de Marina López
explicó que también espera depositar
este un documento similar el hecho es
que según la ley Pues tienen 24 horas
para hacerlo cualquiera de los de los
partidos de la asamblea nacional para
hacer esto y ahora que esperar al menos
unas 48 horas antes de que se dé el voto
para que una moción de censura sea
adoptado pues tiene que hacerlo por la
mayoría absoluta de la asamblea nacional
y de ser así pues simplemente sería el
final del gobierno de la primera
ministra de Francia Elizabeth
era el reporte de Natalia Ruiz desde
París la otra noticia del día está con
un nuevo cambio en el gabinete de Reino
Unido suela previa hermana abandonó en
las últimas horas el Ministerio del
interior después de haber usado su
correo personal para enviar un documento
oficial es la segunda salida en El
Ejecutivo de la Premier League sosten
apenas una semana conectamos en este
momento con nuestra corresponsal en
Londres Luisa Pulido Luisa brideman se
va por una cuestión técnica pero llega
en un momento muy difícil para atrás
quien acaba de nombrar a un nuevo
ministro de finanzas en un momento
económico crítico Cuál es el efecto de
la renuncia de la ministra del interior
un momento muy complejo que pone más
inestabilidad y drama al gobierno
británico y al futuro político de lis
tras cuya permanencia en el 10 de Down
Street Todavía está en veremos su
permanencia está en riesgo hace varios
días en esta carta de Renunciación que
llevaba 43 días en el gobierno aduce
razones éticas pero la carta está llena
de críticas alistras y lo que hace
pensar es que la razón de fondo no fue
esa filtración del correo sino otra dice
además que cuando se está en el gobierno
si se cometen errores deben asumirse
dice textualmente que pretender que no
hemos cometido errores como si nadie
pudiera darse cuenta de que los hemos
cometido y esperar que las cosas salgan
bien por arte de magia no es política
seria y además dice que tiene serias
preocupaciones sobre la dirección del
gobierno del issstras como lo mencionas
y lo cierto Es que en una semana les
trata dos ministros fundamentales para
un gobierno el de finanzas y del
interior lo que nos muestra lo débil
políticamente y la inestabilidad que
tiene el gobierno de lis tras gran chaps
acaba de ser designado como ministro del
interior fue el ministro de transporte
durante el gobierno de Johnson
desde Londres cambiamos de tema hablamos
de la guerra en Ucrania porque el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin declaró
la ley Marcial en los cuatro territorios
ucranianos y legalmente eneccionados por
su país el anuncio fue hecho en una
intervención durante un consejo nacional
de seguridad ese sería un intento por
parte del gremio de recuperar fuerza
ante la pérdida de terreno anti
ucraniano Mientras tanto en gerson miles
de civiles son evacuados por el ejército
ruso en un movimiento que quieras
calificó de propagandístico Andrés
granadillo con el informe
Rusia introduce fuertes medidas en las
cuatro regiones recientemente
anexionadas de Ucrania el presidente
ruso quien culpa a kiev de la situación
y
Permítame recordarles que la ley Marcial
estaba en vigor en la República Popular
de Donnie ex la República Popular de
lugans en las regiones de gerson y
saporilla desde su entrada en el
territorio de Rusia y ahora por lo tanto
es necesario aplicar esta ley dentro del
marco legal ruso
por lo tanto he firmado un decreto sobre
la introducción de la ley Marcial en
estas cuatro zonas de la federación rusa
esta decisión hace parte de la última
escalada por parte del kremlin para
intentar minimizar las derrotas contra
Ucrania en el frente de batalla de hecho
en gerson la primera ciudad que cayó en
manos rusas el ejército visual los
habitantes abandonar la zona ante un
supuesto ataque ucraniano
en esta circunstancia es nuestra
prioridad es preservar la vida y la
salud de los civiles por lo tanto en
primer lugar el ejército ruso
garantizará la salida segura de la
población que ya ha sido anunciada en el
marco del programa de reasentamiento que
está preparando el gobierno en Rusia
pretenden evacuar entre 50.000 y 60.000
personas en los próximos seis días
Tenemos aquí dos filas de personas que
solicitaron a través del centro de
llamadas a la derecha está la fila de
los que se dirigen a olesky y a la
izquierda la fila de los que se dirigen
ahora prestándose mientras Ucrania
intenta recuperar la planta de energía
nuclear de saborilla controlada por
Rusia en la mañana del miércoles un
contingente llegó por lancha hasta el
lugar pero El Avance fue repelido por el
ejército ruso
y en ese contexto el parlamento europeo
entregó en las últimas horas el premio
Sáhara of Sur reconocimiento más
importante en defensa de los Derechos
Humanos al pueblo de Ucrania el
organismo comunitario destacó la defensa
de la libertad de la protección de la
Democracia por parte de los ucranianos
en el hemicidio europeo se reconoció
también el presidente ucraniano por los
Dimitri zelenski se trata del segundo
año consecutivo en el que este galardón
se entrega como contrapeso a Rusia y es
que en la edición anterior el ganador
fue el opositor encarcelado alexey
navali
en la Península de Corea aumenta la
tensión entre el norte y el sur debido a
los ejercicios militares que se están
llevando a cabo por parte de seúl con
Estados Unidos Corea del Norte ha
disparado cohetes en sus cosas en
respuesta y en las últimas semanas ha
enviado misiles que han cruzado el
espacio aéreo de Japón eso se temer por
el futuro de la paz regional
ejercicios militares conjuntos entre
Estados Unidos y Corea del Sur aumentan
la atención en la Península
este simulacro de cruce de Río conjunto
que se lleva a cabo representa un puente
de la solida alianza entre la República
de Corea y Estados Unidos que podría
proteger la vida y la seguridad de
nuestro pueblo de La amenaza de Corea
del Norte en caso de emergencia y
podemos verlo como un atajo hacia una
victoria helicópteros de ataque
surcoreanos lanzaron bengalas al aire
mientras tanques blindados cruzaron el
río nam-han sobre puentes flotantes
construidos durante las prácticas por lo
tanto hemos estado haciendo una
operación combinada de cruce de brecha
húmeda donde los Estados Unidos y la
República de Corea trabajan juntos para
transportar vehículos en balsa y luego
construir un puente de recinto completo
a través de cualquier brecha húmeda muy
probablemente un puente o un río con
puentes que salen en el simulacro de 12
días de duración y que se realiza cada
año participan fuerzas blindadas de
ataque de la décima primera división
móvil del ejército surcoreano la muestra
de militar causó la ira de Corea del
Norte y como respuesta disparó
artillería el martes lanzó unos 100
proyectiles al mar frente a su costa
occidental y disparó otros 150 frente a
la costa Oriental según la agencia de
Estado Mayor conjunto del sur los
últimos disparos se produjeron sobre las
12:30 p.m hora local Según
a detener estos actos que amenazan la
paz de la región
Hablamos ahora de Estados Unidos porque
en Los Ángeles los activistas del
movimiento Black lives matters piden
nuevas renuncias hacen referencia a
otros dos concejales demócratas que
participaron en la llamada junto a Nuri
Martínez la expresidenta del consejo que
prefirió comentarios racistas esto en la
recta final de las elecciones de medio
término
[Música]
gritos contra el racismo en Los Ángeles
es el último escándalo político en
Estados Unidos y va dirigido contra dos
miembros demócratas del concejo
municipal que participaron en una
llamada en la que hacían comentarios
racistas
estamos aquí para decir que Kevin de
León y Gil de Cedillo deben renunciar
ahora
no tenemos lugar para racistas
flagrantes contra los negros en el
concejo municipal de Los Ángeles se
tienen que ir se tienen que ir
los manifestantes quieren que se cierre
el consejo hasta que renuncien pero al
mismo tiempo se celebró un consejo
municipal todavía virtual por el covid19
este consejo no puede avanzar hasta que
tengamos esa renuncias y necesitamos que
todos los miembros del Consejo abandonen
esta reunión rompan el quórum la reunión
se celebró Y tomó posesión el nuevo
presidente Paul grecoriano quien se sumó
a las críticas contra el racismo
Los Ángeles ha visto un rechazo
abrumador a las declaraciones que
hicieron nuestros compañeros
la que sí dimitió la semana pasada es la
expresidenta demócrata del Consejo nury
Martínez fue por la filtración de una
llamada de octubre de 2021 llamó pequeño
mono al hijo de un colega y menospreció
a los mexicanos de Oaxaca la filtración
se produce a semanas de las claves
elecciones legislativas de medio término
y en un ambiente político donde las
protestas de las vidas negras importan
de 2020 Todavía siguen muy presentes
[Música]
hoy se conmemora el Día Mundial de la
lucha contra el cáncer de mama cada año
en Brasil se detectan cerca de 66.000
casos nuevos estudios científicos en
revelan que el 30% de estos casos
podrían ser controlados gracias a una
detección precoz sin embargo la pandemia
del coronavirus ralentizó la realización
de mamografías y de otras pruebas
diagnósticas en este país un tatuador
usa su Don artístico para reconstruir de
manera gratuita los pezones de aquellas
mujeres que pasaron por una mastectomía
y una posterior reconstrucción mamaria
veamos el informe
en abril de 2020 el mundo de Karla se
vino abajo en plena pandemia descubrió
durante un examen de rutina que tenía un
cáncer maligno en el pezón
Uy ya fue el diagnóstico fue complicado
porque porque me pidió en un momento de
sufrimiento
un mes Antes había perdido a mi madre
los médicos se retiraron la areola de su
seno además Carla Tuvo que pasar por un
ciclo de quimioterapia
al final esta mujer consiguió vencer la
enfermedad a sus 41 años solo desea
volver a la normalidad
me siento un poco yo me siento un poco
mutilada no tengo mucho valor de mirarme
en el espejo porque sé que está faltando
una parte de mí mismo
[Música]
Hoy es el día en que Carla va a
recuperar su autoestima gracias al
trabajo solidario de un tatuador
hace 11 años Beto realiza tatuajes
gratuitos a mujeres que perdieron sus
mamás
ya te hicieron un injerto alguna vez
Beto examina los pechos de Carla para
poder copiar exactamente su pezón
es un procedimiento rápido pero muy
preciso en poco más de media hora Beto
tatúa la areola completa el resultado es
espectacular
yo no veía Carla veía otra persona Ahora
estoy viendo a la Carla de verdad
decenas de mujeres han vuelto a sonreír
gracias a la generosidad de este
profesional que no cobra por este
servicio
otros tatuadores en el mundo podrían ver
eso sensibilizarse y ayudar otros
tatuadores podrían unirse a ser la misma
cosa porque no cuesta nada es un trabajo
de 40 minutos que va a dar felicidad a
una mujer por el resto de su vida
Beto sigue cuidando de esas mujeres
incluso después del tatuaje alguna como
Marcia vuelve a por otro un lazo rosa
que identifica a las pacientes
oncológicas
seguimos hablando de esa jornada y nos
despedimos con la exposición del museo
thyssenborne misa de Madrid que presenta
tres réplicas a tamaño real de obras tan
conocidas como la icónica maja desnuda
de Goya pero con una mastectomía se
trataba de piezas que han sido
intervenidas como parte de una campaña
en este día de la lucha contra el cáncer
de mama también figuran réplicas de
rubens y Hans baldum con esas imágenes
Nos despedimos en esta emisión
informativa aquí en France 24
[Música]